welcome to swing on playing nervous
nubby whatever snuba are from Germany
let's see what is doing I'm playing
deform can deform strong move but still
20 seconds but yeah I probably didn't
notice that the game started let's hope
that he actually returns to the board
and not yeah now we have a game 30
seconds head start but yeah you know I
tend to to give away those time edges
really good lip ok Kings Indian let's
play that each three Bishop b5 line this
had been requested hmm can we create
yeah even without night a6 interesting
yeah probably night h5 now really
interesting young hmm I cannot play g4
here do tonight f4 cannot kick it so
probably I should cover their foursquare
ok
hmm this shouldn't be too bad for black
yes yeah yeah I saw that but not much I
could do against it now he's able to
exchange the bishop with bishop f6 okay
yeah well it's not it's not the end of
the world I still have her space
advantage even if he is some getting rid
of his bed bishop wow that's surprising
I really would have expected you should
have six now I can actually drop it back
to have to we can't play Queen e7 bishop
edge flow of course but still it feels
like a slight a slight accomplishment
but ok maybe he's some um yeah seeing it
in a different light that a five was the
necessary prophylaxis ok Bishop aged
horribly Queenie one should i am cherie
prevent bishop age form with the Queen
you one it's very unnatural move but
still come on let's prevent it for the
moment I have I have some time here very
slow very slow type of game long term of
course a 3 B form is the idea
yeah well be fine I don't really believe
be 50 let's see my diet it should should
be okay after b5 I can take c5 and
completely wreck the pawn structure
taking c5 is an idea anyway Wow okay
here's got a three young I see but still
check still there should be some
progress for white to get in before
interesting if I take it if i take it
Bishop takes it to rocky to pick up to a
for sure I don't this is this really
good okay I mean besides all that I can
just take which is not bad still be
takes bishop hmm he can go to a forum
there's no direct refutation to that
yeah well they're they're all good for
what I should play one of the moves even
that one is good now he needs needs to
take situ and after Queen takes young
black just needs to retreat the let's
retreat it white is just just in great
shape even just queen bee three maybe
just queen bee three directly going for
the a pond yeah I can even go here okay
but that's not be too handsy about it
the airport is Sam is not going anywhere
I wanted to prevent a queen F to this
entry
and I can take and play c5 check out but
at the end before hangs Jeff not quite
sure if all this was I was the best
possible way stormy still should be okay
he's got d6 as a week big porn and if he
takes Knight takes saw all nice but I'm
a bit download time 120 against 157 yeah
this Queen is always a bit bit annoying
against the g2 porn but on the other
hand it's also a bit bit far from the
main action on the queenside can take
him now should I just take these six
hard to say what's the most precise I
can clear up to 8 I forgot about the age
and that enter here not good at least
that looks a bit a bit bday looked
exacto look like rock d3 move like that
it cannot play look the one
unfortunately okay maybe reroute the
night to d5 rook to you one it could
have taken take g2 with the maitre don't
be too yeah this is the typical problem
of this of an active night near the king
with little time and this ape on the a
porn is some limiting my king making it
very tricky to play even if it's
subjectively good it's still very tricky
I probably should play King b1 c1 at
some stage yeah this is probably good
anyway the night plunking it right in
the middle of the board rooked you want
yeah you will take a plaque with Clint
away 5 is the birth of big problem
after the exchange I really should be
winning not sure if he has some other
moves time morning I couldn't have
chicken take the night unbelievable
Queen g1 and windy phone check check
check check check no I don't tell me
he's escaping all the way check What
nonsense what in nonsense 21 no white
forfeits on time yeah that's the kind of
game you love to use it's a one-way
street all the way until he's putting up
the first threat was ten seconds down
the clock and then you don't check you
don't really do anything against it just
grade yeah this is just a position that
black can resign of course you just need
to be precise Queen B 6 ma'am this is
this is already at wrong yeah yeah maybe
I'm too optimistic maybe I'm talk
domestic I mean it did it looks like
looks like it should should loose
somehow but it's not easy the comp gives
Queen be one Queen B want to be four
yeah probably this wins but yeah
it's um around here of course it's am
just like a sole plate like you only
need to need to be precise but it's not
not easy it is easy in fact Queen t20
resins because of 25 what I holla okay
so this was the real the real issue
after this what what's the comp
evaluation yeah what's the winds but but
it's tricky as we have seen in the round
here not yet probably I mean of course I
can draw here I mean I saw that but I
wanted to win which was just losing its
just a psychological problem sometimes
if you if you're basically better the
whole game and you think okay I'm going
to win now you know at least it happens
to me that I don't really fight the
right moment to really draw I can hear
of course just just wrong check I should
have redone that but I only really late
realize that I'm man I mean down on the
clock yeah that's one of the Kings
Indian it's notoriously tricky quite
often you have an almost winning
position strategically and it it still
is tricky to play alright thanks for
watching